what is up there reject nation greg and
john here today we are going to watch
the season three
teaser trailer for doom patrol a show
that i've been championing for
last time i covered anything that was
directly doing patrol i hadn't seen the
show yet after fully catching up on it
it is one of the best things i think dc
has ever brought to live action
undoubtedly it's super underrated yeah i
talked with
my buddy aaron many months ago we were
discussing uh season two a lot when it
first came out about covering uh
that together maybe john maybe we'll see
we'll see what's going on
let's talk about it this is my audition
[Music]
tape
there are mysterious things in this
world that they're keeping an eye on me
i think there's something he needs to
show me we appear to be dead
he remembered was there another way or
not
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
[Music]
good old mark shepherd
seen that mark shepard pop up in so many
things lately oh
this is jeremy carver who worked on
supernatural that is
about just as weird as one would expect
the doom patrol trailer to
ultimately be better go about talking
about this i guess this is the thing
where
i bring john on for reactions to things
he hasn't either seen or is not caught
up on yet
i've seen enough to be excited i need to
watch season two of the show
i'm sure i could even say what happens
at the end of season two
briefly and you will not be able to
remember any of what i
say you will not know at all what the
hell i'm talking about
whatsoever so go take it away i mean we
have seen some stuff here
picking up at the end of season two with
the candle maker and dorothy and
obviously they would be fine from the
situation
you do see jane coming out of the well
after discovering that that wasn't
miranda the entire time i had to keep it
up so far
yeah you're doing good i was just so
upset at these spoilers yeah i'm
definitely gonna be thinking about it
like near the end of season two at some
point in the coming weeks
we have a lot more mystery to unpack
within the underground within dorothy
and then this looks like the character
brain uh i don't know who that gorilla
is i'm sure you guys could tell me down
below
if you just go frame by frame there's so
much of i don't know what's happening in
this trailer that's part of the joy that
i have with doom patrol is i i wasn't
at all versed in the comics whatsoever
when it came to the
this group this ip it's just been
completely new for me i watched season
two i started looking up like what are
the differences between the comics and
the show
and all that jazz but i've have retained
barely any of that information
this zany wild wacky ride is just a
part of just a pure delight club
screaming what the [ __ ]
is such a great part doing it saying the
most obvious stuff
of something weird is going on like
that's the whole show something weird is
always going on with this [ __ ]
one of this is going to take place like
you know beyond the the the
veil of death or whatever like i love
this sort of
stream of consciousness pestice style at
least
you know i don't expect the season
necessarily look just like this teaser
but i could definitely imagine
it being at least uh you know a
harbinger of what kind of visual
flourishes there to come because they
always get crazy with their imaginations
well i think
uh those trailers are often this really
fast-paced wackiness which the show does
have that but i think the
show's a lot more poetic than uh the
trailers
ever let on like it's got some really
gripping suspense and drama
and i love that the show is so bonkers
and weird to the point of it's the only
show more than even the boys are for
that matter it's the show that
when you're like they won't go there or
you don't even think about where it
could go and then it just
goes there it just constantly goes there
and i love that about it you know it's
like you know that the show will be a
lot
darker that's that's what i mean i think
it's a lot darker and more character
driven than the trailers ever
truly let on but look into the comments
one of the top comments here is
we get to see the brain and monsieur
mala monster mala i believe
is in young justice and that might be
the gorilla
and it is that gorilla okay i have
discovered who the gorilla is i haven't
done it you could always rely on a solid
youtube comment to
to show you the way a lot of the time in
this trailer we didn't see any of
the chief i'm skimming this and i don't
see the chief anywhere up in here yeah
don't see chief here in the trailer but
i am seeing diane guillermo whatever her
name is guerrero
who plays jane exceptional the standout
performer to me in the show
hit the like button if you agree that
she should at least get an emmy for this
series she absolutely deserves one
and it is one of the most overlooked but
i think just because of the category but
new patrol is in you don't really
consider her for
like lead actress but damn she
absolutely deserves an emmy
a thousand percent and it's amazing to
me that we got this coming you know i'm
always a little worried that dune patrol
is going to get cancelled you know
it's always right there on the cusp of
will it come back will it not come back
so
it's always a breath of fresh air to
come to find out that it does come back
because even with season two
a lot of people might not even know this
but with season two it was supposed to
have ten episodes and they had the
pandemic going on
that they had to end it at nine episodes
so they they had a whole episode that
they wanted to do
but they had to tie up some threads and
leave it on a good cliff hanger which i
think they successfully managed to do
just shows the strength of the writers
here on the series because i think even
if you didn't know that
it would still feel like a pretty solid
season too would they have tied up more
threats most likely would they have
tried to
acknowledge more things i'm sure they
would have but in terms of ending on
a season two with the cliff hanger that
they had i'm like no that seems like a
pretty solid spot to end it at so again
just kudos to the writers for doing this
and i'm so grateful for this show like
this show is the one
that really showcased to me this is the
potential of what dc has in terms of
going weird and bizarre now it's just
about
audiences latch onto it that's why the
suicide squad really excited me because
it is
not as weird as this but it's certainly
weird and i
i kind of like that about dc and i want
them to keep going down that
path it's a good time to be a dc fan
considering all the weirdness that we
get in store here for what to explore
i mean i even saw a billboard for titan
season three outside of the local ralphs
that i shop at and
and this just the billboard alone made
me go i i think i'm going to start this
show up now's the time now is the time
to start it up man
all right guys well doom patrol season
three what do you think
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell hit that
like button
and do our best to cover it covering hbo
mac shows uh or hbo shows in general can
be a little bit tough we're gonna do our
best to cover here for the youtubes
we'll see you guys
tyler hague you would be the obvious
pick to be the robo man of this channel
dude you are a
cliff you're a big you know guy who
could easily decimate somebody but you
got a soft
heart my dude plus if we had to find
ourselves on some kind of
madcap insane adventures there's nobody
i would rather
have backing us up because i know that
you would have us both
in the physical realm you would be able
to protect us but also you would be able
to keep our morale
up tyler you would be able to keep us
feeling all right about ourselves
keep us together as a loving family unit
you're the soul of this doom patrol th
got your initials and i'd be there for
you because that sucked your dick
[Music]